the unfolding of the story may be slower
than we're used to in the movies
but it's changing the marvel universe
faster than we ever could have imagined
the appearance of one character in
particular left us completely floored
what do all of these developments mean
for the future of mcu
let's have a look you didn't tell me you
had plans
the major shocker of the show thus far
was the introduction of evan peters's
pietro in episode 5.
what's mysterious about his presence is
that we don't exactly know
which pietro he is from what we've
gathered the personality seems
most similar to the x-men version and
his memories from the marvel version
pietro becoming a focal point in the
series opens the possibility for other
fox characters to appear on the show
as for the future of mcu it seems as
though character crossovers and
multiverses could become a norm
making the franchise able to grow in
ways we never could have anticipated
it's cool i know i look different with
the mystery of pietro still up in the
air
it's hard to say exactly how he exists
in this world
however if we consider that the new
spider-man will also feature former
spider-mans
pietro's introduction in wandavision
could imply that multiple characters
could exist across
multiple universes with the ability to
travel across these universes no less
time travel when wanda said
no more mutants in the comic house of m
it wiped out pretty well all mutant kind
if this is indeed the x-men version of
pietro then
that means that mutants are back and
more could appear
in the show and future projects
fundamentally changing the series and
mcu who are you
we know that monica has been discouraged
from going back into the hex
since there is proof in her blood work
that she's changing on a molecular level
since this is the case and wanda
expanded the hex to include more people
does it mean all of their molecular
formations have changed
if so we're not only looking at the
possibility of existing mutants being
introduced in the mcu
but the creation of multiple mutants as
a result of the hex
this means we could potentially see new
characters added to the mcu roster
thanks for thanking of me episode 5 had
a brief mention of captain marvel
well i'd argue that captain marvel came
close which monaco was
quick to avoid this could indicate a few
things
a is there some unknown drama between
lieutenant trouble
and captain marvel that could appear in
a future mcu production
b earlier in her career she was known as
captain marvel herself
since we're realizing there is a
possibility that multiple versions of
characters may exist in mcu now
does this mean there could be two
captain marvels
either options could lead to major
changes in the mcu
you got something for me while the
sokovian accent coming out
may have been a slip up due to an
emotional moment it could
also mean that she might still be under
the influence of hydra
while the organization is defunct in
both mcu and agents of shield
this clue indicates hydra may still
exist in some capacity
especially since it's been included in
many commercials
the strucker watch has hydra written on
the face and the luxury bath soak
advertised
is called hydrosoak these inclusions
feel like more than just a coincidence
if hydra is really back then it could
play a huge role in future mcu
productions
well then we have to protect it we
already know that wandavision is leading
us into the next doctor strange film so
it could be possible that he appears in
one division as well
since wanda seems to be losing control
it would make sense for him to show up
since in the comics
doctor strange once limited the powers
of the scarlet witch when she was
becoming too powerful
this further emphasizes the idea of
multiverses and potential future
character crossovers with doctor strange
and multiple spider-mans appearing in
the new spider-man
it seems as though future mcu
productions are going to be filled with
crossovers
i know what you're going to say you
should not be here the commercials have
been one of the most unique aspects of
one division by far
and could indicate a style change in
future mcu productions
this clever tool to drop references and
potential hints could be used again in
the future
the tv show format and unique inclusions
may be a bold and exciting move toward
telling the mcu stories in more
varied genres and styles lagos
for when you make a mess you didn't mean
to
though the change to the acronym sword
from sentient world observation and
response department
to sentient weapon observation response
division
has yet to be explained in one division
we can conclude this
potentially affects the entire mcu
changing world
to weapon indicates the goal of the
agency is not only to pay attention to
alien risks
but also to superheroes who aren't able
to control their powers
you never know you hope for the best
from what we can gather from the show
thus far it seems pretty obvious that
wanda's quickly growing children
tommy and billy will grow up to be the
young avengers
this could mean that the original mcu
avengers have been retired to make room
for new content focused on the young
avengers team
a huge change to the mcu
next stop cabiny town the soon-to-be
young avengers tommy and billy have
inherited powers from wanda and pietro
a major indicator that mutations can be
passed on in this series
that is if that's what they're being
considered in this world
if so mutation having the ability to be
passed genetically
radically shifts dynamics in the mcu
isn't it
the idea that agnes is actually agatha
harkness
is pretty probable especially
considering the amount of hints that
have been dropped throughout the series
the witch costume she wore in episode 6
really confirmed it for us
as well as the fact that sword doesn't
know who she is
a witch being added to the mix would be
a major change for mcu
considering there's always been a focus
on science
combining the worlds of mysticism and
science
would lead to a big dynamic shift
between characters as well
since we don't know the extent of
mythical powers that could exist in mcu
okey dokey neighbor with wando's
emotional outburst and the expansion of
the hex in episode vi
we can conclude her powers are far
greater than we originally thought
what could happen if she uses her powers
to her full potential
wanda is becoming more and more of a
major player in the mcu world
and since we're seeing the multiverse
possibilities explode
this could lead to a new mcu era with
wanda as a major leader
due to the success of one division and
the appeal the episodic style has for
the comic book lovers
it is very likely that mcu will lean
towards making more mcu tv shows
the format allows for more thorough and
detailed storytelling
rather than the movies that have to cut
a lot of the backstory or details and
plots due to time restrictions
characters are getting more focused on
their individual stories
and with the falcon and the winter
soldier loki and hawkeye coming
the way mcu is telling stories is
inevitably changing
yes yes we've been pondering over the
question of vision's future since we've
noticed some clues that indicate
he might come back the first is the
heart on the date august 23rd
in episode one in the avengers comic
number 238
vision is reactivated the second clue
the strucker watch ad with the time on
the clock appears at 2
42 the avenger comic number 242
is the one in which vision is repaired
after his deactivation
coincidences we hope not if he is
brought back to life
mcu would be welcoming back a major
player once again
leading to more storylines with vision
included
why would you think that so far we've
been blown away with the quality and
intricacy that one division has
demonstrated
the marvel cinematic universe has
definitely changed and we're looking
forward to seeing where it goes from
here
how long will we have to wait for a
young avengers focused movie or
show we can't wait